moi je trouve monsieur sympa Mondon par
ailleurs très habile encore une fois de
lever du conseil de Monsieur Parisot
mais lui il arrive toujours avec des
propositions inattendues et quand c'est
inattendu ça suscite notre intérêt on en
parle les médias en parlent ils se
positionnent il veut aller chercher
probablement des souverainistes qui ont
voté CAC à la dernière élection avec ce
gouvernement kakis qui a quand même
depuis le mois d'octobre des dossiers
qui vont pas si bien que ça j'espère les
récupérer puis espère qu'effectivement
on va faire revivre cette fibre
souverainiste mais Monsieur le goût lui
pourquoi lui est d'accord oui on va tout
se dire même le PLQ va dire oui on est
tous pour la transparence ça paraît très
mal comme politicien de dire qu'on n'est
pas pour la transparence mais en même
temps quand tu regardes le rapport
grenier ce sont très très major
clairement des libéraux fédéraux puis
des libéraux provinciaux qui ont été
qui ont été questionnés alors pour
laquelle avantage politique parce que il
va avoir des révélations des noms qui
vont sortir et des réputations
effectivement et ces gens-là ne pourront
pas
requestionné en contre-interrogatoire
des personnes de l'époque puis ces
gens-là on pourra pas vérifier les
versions mais ça quel gouvernement
décide j'ai pas de problème avec ça
parce que effectivement ça fait partie
de notre histoire puis normalement ben
ce serait 25 ans dans le conseil des
ministres les documents sont préservés
pendant 25 ans alors ça fait partie de
l'histoire faut faire face à notre
histoire mais il faut y faire face avec
des vrais faits avec des vérités puis il
faut y faire face correctement
correctement comme une société civilisée
alors moi j'ai pas de doute que ça va
arriver puis que ils vont c'est
juridiquement ils peuvent le faire ils
vont le faire maintenant je termine en
disant que le juge grenier n'avait pas
la juridiction et le mandat d'évaluer
les activités du gouvernement fédéral
soyez tout de suite très clair il est
très
clairs
spécifiquement sur le référendum tu as
raison Dimitri
tout ce qui est secret devient tellement
inintéressant une fois rendu public
vraiment
donc
attendons voir quand les documents vont
être rendu public parce que les
conclusions sont les conclusions 540
000 l'argent Option Canada
l'enquête grenier était tellement limité
mais écoutez entre nous là on peut
fermer le poste pour 30 secondes
des deux côtés est-ce qu'il y a des gens
tant du côté du oui que du comté du côté
du nom qui ont essayé peut-être de voter
deux fois ou trois fois
c'était l'avenir du pays qui se jouait
donc je suis certain que à l'époque des
deux côtés on a essayé de contourner des
règles on a essayé d'avoir plus de votes
qui disent oui plus de vote qui disent
non
c'était c'était c'était probablement une
mère la plus polarise polarisante
de mon époque je me souviens j'étais
j'étais adolescent à l'époque je faisais
bien sûr campagne pour pour le nom
mais de questionner c'est là où je dis
oui à ce que exige monsieur
saint-pierre-clamondon puis c'est
probablement le le communicateur le plus
stratégique avec seulement deux députés
et lui trois il réussit à dominer
je n'ai aucun problème avec sa demande
donc j'ai un problème c'est là où il
sort le PlayBook de Donald Trump où il
essaie de dire que le résultat a été
volé j'ai écouté son entrevue sur tout
un matin il faut faire attention
demander que des documents puissent
cette enquête les documents en arrière
de cette enquête soit rendu public pas
de problème mais de dire que le oui a
gagné le référendum en 1995 et et
vous savez c'était probablement puis je
conclus en disant ceci
1995 était probablement l'année où le
département
d'Immigration Canada était le plus
efficace parce qu'ils ont ils ont
accéléré
l'octroi de citoyenneté que si ce
monsieur qui puisse c'est une stratégie
à l'époque donnant le plus grand nombre
de citoyenneté aux demandeurs donc
peut-être que le PQ peut former le
gouvernement faire la menace de notre
référendum le monsieur qui attend depuis
2006 va finalement avoir sa réponse
parce qu'il y en a qui pensent que c'est
ce que je veux je veux que ce soit en
cachette ma préoccupations c'est un
retour était la même comme comme avocat
c'est la protection du témoin qui
témoigne à 8 lots qui obtient
l'autorisation et ça pour moi c'est
extrêmement important
si on peut regarder les noms d'accord
parce que ça on en aurait pas des laters
si on commence à simplement dire et on
envoie tout ça dans la sphère publique
et au diable les conséquences moi à ce
niveau là j'ai des petites réticences je
voulais le bien le préciser
Jean-François en conclusion en 45
secondes s'il vous plaît alors je
parfaitement d'accord avec Françoise
c'est un engagement été pris avec un
témoin cet engagement doit être respecté
pour l'État
je m'inscris en faux contre le fait de
dire mais tout le monde a frauder non
suivant les faits suivant les procès
suivant les documents
toutes les toutes les demandes qui ont
été faites ont été suivies et des
enquêtes ont été faites pas sur les
dépenses
publiques du Québec c'est une enquête
directeur général
des élections ont été examinée il y a eu
une enquête sur la ligation de fraude
qui a eu lieu dans son BD
goal qui avait pas québécois je veux
juste
en disant ceci
évidemment politique une fois que le
référendum est fini on peut dire ce
qu'on veut par la suite il est fini puis
politiquement le nom a gagné mais
puisque le grenier nous dit que en plus
des 11 millions de dollars fédéraux qui
ont été dépensés légalement pour aider
le nom donc le nom avait trois fois plus
d'argent que le OUI pour faire la
campagne ils ont dépensé un demi million
illégalement si on était aux Jeux
Olympiques on enlèverait la médaille
d'or à Ottawa parce qu'ils ont été dopé
mais on n'est pas en olympique on est en
politique voilà pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI